your family are they are they here my
family's here visiting from India yeah
that's so cool yeah thank you
Wow Wow
I think here backstage backstage yeah
that's what I was saying someone told me
just like before we came back from
commercial that your family's actually
backstage are they are you showing them
around town I I mean I I just I'm
horrible at being famous because they
want to see like celebrity sightings and
everything and the other day we were
walking down the street I haven't shown
them any celebrities or whatever because
you know I don't know I'm just not good
at that stuff we were walking on the
street and we saw paparazzi so I was
like oh come on guys like not right now
please you know and they walk pass they
walk right past me some starlet oh yeah
know what I mean yeah and we don't know
who the star that is so I'm literally
asking the paparazzi who the person it
is at the taking photographs of right
and they're like oh and I'm like hey
that's great man thanks for letting me
know have a great day that I came agree
have a great day buddy your family's
very sweet and they didn't know it was
me
well maybe they thought it was mean they
didn't care so I really haven't been
doing a good job while showing them
around that let your family down you
didn't they want to see you get mobbed
by paparazzi absolutely they want to see
me get more by paparazzi and I in fact I
was the one stalking the paparazzi I was
like hey check that I was like
pretending but the corner of my eye was
hoping that notice me yeah yeah playing
up my accent and like kind of doing some
lines from the show and stuff doing
lines so dumb I was you see saying my
lines from the show in my act didn't
work yeah my whenever my people come to
town they always want to see a celebrity
I'm like I don't I don't know where to
go to find it you know what I mean yeah
you come to my show you'll see a
celebrity but you're not gonna see one
just you can't go to any frogurt stand
no you know what I mean oh and Stan just
walk up to Barbra Streisand's house and
ring the bell I have you actually we did
it yeah she got mad
you